so we start with that breaking news and
the court in kigali has sentenced the
man whose life inspired the hollywood
film hotel rwanda to 25 years in prison
on terrorism charges paul recess
beginner is credited with sheltering and
saving hundreds of people during the
country's genocide in 1994 but he fell
out with the president said let's go
straight away to kigali malcolm whereby
our correspondent is standing by there
malcolm tell us more what's been
happening
well the judges have been reading out uh
their judgments in this courthouse for
the last six hours and they've just got
to the verdict and they said just a
short while ago that recessor beginner
is guilty of the various terror related
charges that he was facing and he's been
sentenced to 25 years in jail along with
20 co-accused around him we've also been
found guilty of various charges and
given
jail sentences but lesser jail sentences
but recessor beginner himself isn't in
the courtroom there he refused to turn
up and he's done so for the last six
months of court hearings because he said
this trial wasn't fair that's something
that's been echoed by international
observers as well so he hasn't attended
any of these hearings
and his supporters including his
daughter who we spoke to a short while
ago completely rejected
this trial they say it's not legitimate
at all
what recourse might recessive beginner
have or is that it is there any room for
appeal here
yeah there is a possibility for the
prosecution or for the defense to appeal
this judgment within 15 days
what the
we don't know if recessive beginner or
his lawyers intend to do that i mean
they've rejected this entire process by
virtue of
not turning up so we don't know if
if they're going to engage with it from
here on but the criticisms other
criticisms of the process by
international observers
have included the fact that the evidence
submitted and there was some evidence
that processor beginner had been
involved
with opposition groups and some armed
groups but they said that evidence was
never actually evaluated
in the court that key witnesses weren't
allowed to be cross-examined uh by the
defense
and so legal experts had said that any
verdict that came out of here would lack
would lack credibility in whatever
whatever the case
all right malcolm thanks for that
malcolm webb there and kigali on that
guilty verdict